you have to make sure that you work on
the best possible game don't race your
time in something you don't believe in
work on the stuff that matters and make
sure that you have the vision right
we'll get some mobile game developer
based in Berlin at our headquarters here
we have more than 250 employees we
produce high quality mobile games that
are being played by more than 50 million
players every month the most popular
games are diamond - jelly splash and
agent Alice agent Alice is a hidden
object game launched on February 26
agent Alice got 9 million downloads to
date six of them coming from Google Play
and Android only we released a new
episode every single week to keep
players engaged and to keep them active
over a very long time Google Play
allowed us to run fast iterations for
agent others all new features and
updates are being developed and right
first before they come to other
platforms our business is very fast so
or development up which has to be also
very fast or develop a cycle is usually
one to two weeks and this discipline
Google Play is a clear winner we can
just publish and release or games within
hours this is what we really do have
already in the prototyping and
concepting phase we can leverage the
beta testing feature on Google Play the
staged rollout helps us to release a new
feature only to a tiny set of users to
make sure that everything is stable and
that is actually perceived well the
combination of Google Play and Google
Analytics enables us to understand our
users even better looking into the
different KPIs we can make sure that we
understand where our users are coming
from tracking different steps during the
first-time user experience helps us to
understand when a user is potentially
leaving the game whenever that happens
we can iterate extremely fast and make
sure that we optimize those points to
make sure that users stay even longer in
our game
we have to make sure that the image
quality is the best possible on whatever
screen you look however we usually don't
want to put huge graphics that are being
displayed on a tablet into a game that
is being played on a phone this is the
reason why we love the multi apk feature
of Google Play it helps us to bundle our
games to make sure that the file size is
as small as possible for the individual
users use the full potential of the fast
iterations and make your game with every
durations better and better
[Music]